Less than Europe means less power for France.
I will only take one example
and it will hurt some here,
the Brexit.
These supporters promised
happy days to the British economy
and the English people.
Last week,
because of the Brexit,
the last ones in the oven in Great Britain have closed.
Steel is no longer produced in the UK.
We in France,
on the contrary,
thanks in particular to investments from Europe,
the industry returns.
Who was
who was the first supporters in France of the Brexit?
Who in the cities he runs from the streets,
streets of Brexit,
which was displayed
openly with the leader of the Brexit camp,
is the National Rally.
Europe,
Europe
eternal bouquet-emissary of those who wrong
to be able to lead 1 country,
want to destroy everything,
1 continent.
Not 1 Frenchman thinks we can
move from Europe.
Not 1 French either
believes that Europe has fully found
the right place in his life.
They are right,
not everything is perfect.
There are still work to be done,
but the facts are there.
With Europe,
our power is multiplied
and in recent years,
we have started to change it
and I solemnly say it
at the time it is midnight -1 in the century.
Faced with,
the masks will have to fall off.
We may want to change Europe for the country's interest,
and we do.
But we can't want
to leave Europe,
except to have other interests,
except to serve 1 other country,
1 other power.